Let's go next to our caller from the six eight
two area code.
Who is calling today from six eight two six
eight two.
Are you there?
It sounds like you might have us muted six
eight two last chance.
If you've got us muted, this is the time to
take us off.
All right.
No, six, eight, two.
Let's go instead to our caller from the three
zero seven area code.
Who's calling today from three zero seven.
Can you hear me?
Yes, I can.
Um, I have a question about the like about
establishment Democrats.
Okay.
So like, um, why are establishment Democrats
like that?
Like, like, like, you know, I know many establishment
Democrats are, again, let's not fight Medicare
for all and free college, but why?
Well, what you have to understand is that
a centrist Democrat is very similar to a centrist
Republican.
And in fact, in a lot of countries, Centrus
Democrats would probably be part of a moderate
right wing party more than they would a moderate
left wing party.
Particularly in countries that have an actual
progressive party.
So moderate centers, Democrats want to basically
perpetuate the same status quo that we have
in terms of the relationship between the centers
of power corporations, the elites, uh, et
cetera.
They are funded by a lot of the same interests,
so it's basically like different wrapping,
a very similar underlying products.
That's why they end up being very similar
to Republicans because they are in most ways.
Yeah.
Do you think like the art establishment Democrats,
I like, they believe in free college or theirs
and that is just like so crap.
They don't work.
They don't vote for it.
I mean you're trying to guess what's in people's
heads, right?
You're trying to get it.
It's in the same way that it's possible that
a centrist could publicly say, I'm not for
free college, but like privately before it,
you could also have someone who is more progressive
in their public facing side that says therefore
free college but aren't really for it, but
they know it's not likely to happen.
So they just say that.
I mean you, there's always people who are
saying things because they're trying to build
up their public persona in a certain way and
they're not being genuine.
I don't think it's really important to dwell
on that because you're ultimately, you're
trying to read what's in people's minds, what
matters is what they do and say publicly because
that's what ultimately gets things done.
Yeah, I understand that.
But I'm from Wyoming, like we don't, like
a lot of our Democrats are like, like I mean
in Wyoming, like lot of our Democrats can
be like more progressive, but we don't have
a lot of stuff.
Establishment Democrats.
Interesting.
That surprises me.
Yeah.
Cause we, we supported, uh, [inaudible] caucus
and we voted for Bernie and we're going to
do that again.
And I know they're like more Salish and Democrats
and like the Northeast.
Do you think?
I don't, you know, there, so there's a co
there's a problem with that analysis.
So for example, in Massachusetts you have
a lot of like Kennedy style, old school Democrats,
and then you've got progressive in other parts
of the country, the more centrist Democrats
are not really Kennedy style Democrats.
There are more blue dog Democrats that are
often more socially conservative.
So I think that you have Centrus Democrats
all over the country and they're different
in different parts of the country.
In the Northeast, they're more kind of like
old money Kennedy type Democrats in the South.
You've got the blue dogs in Wyoming.
I don't know what you have.
It sounds like you've got a mix of different
things.
Um, but I, I think you've got to look at it
in a little more detail.
I appreciate the call.
Thank you so much.
Really great to hear from you.